hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the mortuary
assistant
i'm going to get these endings
i want to get all of them i didn't think
that i would but i'm going to right now
there is something else here
in this apartment
something pertaining to that thing that
i was alluding to in the last one i
wasn't sure but i didn't want to go into
this wasting my time so somewhere in
here maybe right now maybe not now
is something to find
there is
a coin of some kind
here
i just don't know where let me try to
get the basement ending first
and then i'll see about this something
else but just keep it in the back of
your mind that there is something else
here but i'm going to open up the
basement and i'm going to get down to
business down there because i'm going to
get the basement ending i don't know why
i didn't get it last time but i didn't
get it and i'm upset
i need answers from mr d evans
[Music]
devons i don't know but let's get to
work of things
who do we got you
jesse whatever
you i didn't even see the name
it's a secretly meet was that the name
scaredy matt
really
scaredy matt your name is scaredy matt
fredrick galvin and scaredy matt jessica
something frederick and scaredy matt
really
all right you guys have fun do whatever
you want to do be all adventurous and
whatnot
feel free to move around
uh
interesting
in the night shift
database oh i'll get that later
531392 i probably won't remember that
all right there was that thing in the
sky again
whatever
i can't use that here yes i can
hello oh you're open
why are you open hello
what
what are you just open because i opened
you before and you're gonna stay open
i'm missing something
hmm that's bizarre
i'm thinking it's just because i opened
it before and i don't need to do it
again maybe i don't even need to get the
hatch key again i don't like it i don't
like it at all
oh
god i'm gonna try scaredy mad here
[Music]
backwards p
don't mind me
same house
every time
oh god do i remember
ah damn it
531392 isn't that what i put in
[Music]
backwards p there's only one with i have
the name already so it's magnifying
beaker umbrella p
or nine whatever
just gonna take this and i'm gonna just
you know
see what happens
how do you like that
you like that
interesting
well i guess i got you
man that was that's got to be some kind
of a record
that has to be some kind of a record i
still need to get the baleful reagent in
ya
oh that's not good oh i don't like that
oh i don't like that
what was that oh god what was that
what was the creaking
[Applause]
it's always the subtle things that get
me spooked more than anything else
you give me a big shadowy demon standing
in the hallway i'm fine
[Applause]
oh boy that's not good
oh boy oh hey it's you again right this
thing i don't have it i i ain't got it i
ain't got the thing
but i'll get in a bit
i gotta burn this body i don't even know
about the need to fill this up i think
it's something about yeah when you put
the mark on the body and hold it there
for a while these scratches do appear
all right
let's go
unless it's like trying to throw me off
and then that's not the right thing
oh boy oh frick no
hello
excuse me you smiling
either you smiling nah okay uh well i'ma
burn it somehow seems like i might have
just you know nailed it
wham
any objections good
i almost made it of course it could be
wrong i don't know
kind of weird to think that i could get
it on the exact first try oh boy
uh oh
whoa what
whoa what what
what
what's happening
oh my god hello mr dover
okay
what
it didn't even give me an ending was
that the basement ending but i don't
think it was it said that the basement
and it was his own separate thing how
are you gonna do that to me
what
that doesn't make any sense what just
happened if he locked me in the basement
did that mean that i got possessed why
would i get possessed because i got the
demon perfectly
unless i didn't
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
what
the hell
that's weird it's 531392 what
i can't use that here
yeah
backwards p there's only one backwards p
demon in invidious
unless i'm stupid backwards p there is
only one
what
there we go
i'm confused
[Music]
what was that what did i just see play
that back again
what was that okay i don't know what
happened but i'm just gonna continue
forward maybe the game doesn't like it
if you only have gotten one name
maybe it's like there's no way you could
get it right and it just like craps out
on you maybe he was just pissed off that
i didn't do the rest of my job and get
to the other bodies like processed
old man dervings is just upset you
didn't do your job
this is what happens to all the other
employees that i fire
for not doing their job
i'm all over it don't you worry about a
thing mr duvenmeyer
do i even need this anymore i kind of am
good
i kind of know what i'm doing so i'll
just get thing cleaner i can't use that
here okay i can
uh maybe it's
maybe it's not gonna be happy if i don't
do it in the right order oh why why oh
why oh why why did you just do that
i don't like that
no boy
no
no boy it's you again god it's you again
all right
hmm
pie
was that one of them that's not
here but the sign on him
nine pi house of desolation
interesting so it had i must have had
the wrong one but i thought that if you
put the symbol with the ash that that
got it so pi that
z9
wait that's not what i put in there
zoom in on that mark it's different
that's pi at the top z on the right
that on the bottom nine on the left
that's not what i put in there
all right
maybe i should just pick this up
all right so if it isn't you
if it's not
this one i think i just got to keep
going on this because
it's got to be something that i'm
missing i'm trying to get too fancy
about it i'm trying to make a right call
when i've only got a little bit of
information
i better just like try to do it right
oh did you just smile
did you just change over to a smile
[Music]
no that's just what you look like
all right
are you sure this is the right one maybe
just feeling it out
don't worry about it
just stay nice and calm with that thing
on your chest
stan asking call
see even there it looks like the wrong
one
oh no
oh no oh there i
am well i'm back here
i'm missing something that's good to
know um
probably missing my keys right
oh
you'd be hiding in boy place your dad's
being a total [__] loser
ran down to the beach in just a sec grab
your kitten get down here
without you
oh no thank you
no thank you
so this means that like when
uh i went to the beach
i overdosed or something and then that's
where you hit your head and fell this to
me
is all your fault
good
so really is trying to like exploit the
guilt but who knows how long ago that
actually was
did i not put all the
things in here i can't hold anything
else
i guess i could console my clipboard
methanol i knew it anything change over
here
different
oh
no oh
no
what
oh don't do that don't
do
that you're not different you're no
different
you're no different you haven't moved
nothing's really changing
this is
bizarre this is very bizarre
the other one though
had scratches on it
that's what threw me off that's why i
was like oh definitely it's that one
for sure
but apparently not
whatever
why are you wiggling
you wiggling so much
why you so jiggly
rebecca oh boy
yes
oh my god wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute oh god oh
god oh god wait a minute
what the frick what the frick
okay well that
is interesting
yes who is it
it's you
i knew it was you
i knew it all along
i mean
uh-huh that thing it is you because you
were the one that was standing in the
window or in the doorway you were in
there i saw
the thing on your stomach the brand it
is you
it is you
it's definitely you and i don't know if
i need to go through this whole
rigmarole just to do this
apparently i do
all right so i got to finish off this
one but
with that being said i know which one it
is
why
oh this again
fascinating
rebecca
uh-huh
okay yeah
yep
[Music]
interesting
so
little raymond thinks he found a
replacement
man this was just spelling it out for me
i don't know how i didn't get this
before
it was really laying it on thick
oh why were you looking at me
[Applause]
let's just get lucky with the key oh
they look at you
hello
well that's not new
but what is interesting is this is
closed now
i've been here this is closed now as
well
hello
yes
oh i knew you'd find me
[Music]
oh
ah
look at this
who
are you
now
yes yes
look at you look at you look at you
is raymond here
do you see what he's doing who could do
this to someone ah
i think you should let me out
you'll be here soon
peek-a-boo i wonder if this is a hint
the symbols on this i wonder if they
mean something or if that's just the
specific seal for this demon that's in
here
you know i talk anymore
i believe that i had to do that
in order to make this all work
well i'm not doing so good i better
hurry up but that answers that question
i guess i was supposed to look in the
viewport
which you know
i suppose i should have known
where was i
right tank cleaner did i get it no oh
why again why why why
it's probably fine tank cleaner that's
probably fine
it's probably fine it's definitely fine
definitely fine
okay it's fine
oh okay interesting
uh oh
oh not this again
all right well i guess i gotta go
through this again
so i'm pretty sure
it's the other one
i'm pretty sure
[Music]
i don't think i am are you sure
yeah cause i saw you in the bathroom
kind of not really being sneaky about
that i'm pretty sure
god if i get a wrong body thing again
there was like no other signs except you
did
get scratches all over you
i'm pretty sure
oh
raymond
i'm here
i can't
believe you
what you've been doing is
monstrous i've said already that i've
had to accept everything about myself
just like you do this is a necessary
evil it's sick
she's down there right now just
suffering for no reason valerie is not
down there
not
anymore she's been gone for years you
don't know that
yeah
you're just gonna let her stay there
you don't know
what she's feeling you are torturing her
she's helping me survive
she's helping us survive
without her there's no reagent without
the reagent we have nothing
you want to have a chance at life it
comes with a cost
this cost
you have to make a choice
just like i did what choice
keep her alive to just bleed her over
and over again to save ourselves
if she can't be saved end the torture
she's down there suffering for your own
gain i gain
my gain
you used her too
it didn't stop you from finishing the
job
you used her blood anyway
when it came down to it
you chose survival
just like i did
i can't kill her rebecca
i know it's the right thing to do for
her
i know
but she isn't the only one what
i've seen many experience what you did
none have
survived
i've watched them degrade and suffer
until they're no longer themselves
i didn't know what else to do
i couldn't just let them suffer
i searched for years to find a way to
reverse it
all i found was the way to prevent more
isn't that better than nothing
i've killed them all rebecca
it was the only thing i could do
so yes
i am a monster
but this one horrible thing has
prevented me from having to take any
more life
and i would choose that again and again
i can't live with any more death than i
already do
i've made peace with it
the choice is yours if you can too
i'll see you tomorrow
so what you're saying is life is ours to
choose
but that's interesting okay finally got
that ending definitely
i i guess i was just led astray by the
ash thing
i don't know why i thought that burned
the symbol
that
it was unless maybe it's a thing where
the symbol has to match up still with
what it is
i'm not sure but there's one more ending
there's one more ending and i'm going to
find it and it all starts in this room
that i'm in
excuse me it all starts in this room
right here
there is a coin
somewhere in this room and i have yet to
find it
there really aren't that many places to
look which is strange
unless it's like underneath something
kind of oh
[Music]
i love you dad
ah
i see
it was like in the thing with the other
thing but that's what i need because i'm
pretty sure i am pretty sure
you use that with the version of
yourself that is hanging
and that
is the final ending and i'm gonna get it
mine is probably some easter eggs here
and there that like require some very
minute adjustments here and
doing whatever but let's get to it
already
where was that oh there we go
uh we got nose
all right so we got milo mercer
we've got zachary vincent
and we got eda benton
all y'all are gonna have a great time
with me today
let's just start with you
your first step i wonder what happens if
you go down and talk to the person in
the basement again
i wonder if you can
might as well find out
nah you can't
you can't
why not i don't know
i feel like there would be a lot of
conversating to be had some secret
insights maybe the outfit
that's fine
i 9687 we got nosman
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god
oh
oh it's just you it's just you it's just
you what's up
hello
just you
that's fine
okay we got
side nose
nose and nose could be tell duke
okay it's either tell duke or ooze
current
tell duke or oozegrid
what
what was that what happened
okay
man the same people keep dying every
single day
it's weird you know
there we go
oh no visitors
[Music]
oh boy
where is it
oh
okay we got curvy doo
so curvy dot
nose nose curvy dot nine is that also on
the other one
nose nose nope
it's that one nose nose curvy.9
are you sure this is the right one
no not quite but you know we're gonna
find out
we're gonna find out seems to be a high
probability that it's typically this one
i think it's been you a lot which
probably means that it's not gonna be
you this time if i just had to guess
oh
interesting
that matches up with this house of
desolation
so that matches up to what oh
what i thought you were
[Music]
oh what was that
oh
hi okay yeah that matches up to what i
thought you were but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you were the one
are you smiling
is that a smile
that's hard to tell
that's a smile
that's a smile wait a minute
wait a minute
so why can't i i can't use that here i
can take it off but i can't put it on
when they're on their beds
i can't use that weird
so uh take this
smiley
are you smiling
oh
no no no no no you don't get to do that
oh you are definitely the one
hi hey where are you going
where you going
come back
oh interesting
[Music]
okay
so the one thing i do know about this
place
is that there is
the hanging girl me
yeah
[Music]
high-risk wing keys
and then
i'm thinking
this is what i do with the coins
hello
this is what i do
i can't use that here
i can't use i can't use that here what
do you mean
my ten-year coin right
so then
i can't use that here
i can't use i can't use that
okay maybe i just need to remember this
because when you appear in the hallway
maybe that'll be different
i can't use that okay
you shall die
so that is the answer i need to get when
you're in the hallway not here
necessarily because i couldn't do
anything here
so
man it
that was appearing in the hallway all
the time and then suddenly nothing
there's got to be an answer there it's
got to be an answer it's got a ah maybe
there's some way that it can be
triggered i don't know
anyway i haven't even inspected you
back to work yeah
why are your eyes closed
why are your eyes should not be closed
already
oh that's weird
i don't like that
there we go um okay all right blissful
sleep huh
what what happened what happened what
happened i don't know
oh
boy
oh boy
okay
no it wasn't oh
interesting
i think you're trying to throw me off
your trail
not true that's not what it is you're
clearly
clearly the one
oh now yeah okay yeah okay you're
telling me you're not the one okay
okay all right but this doesn't help me
because i do not have the
thing in the hallway
spawning never thought i'd be asking for
ghosts to attack me but i think i need
it
okay
how about no
how about no what if i just say no
don't you love your grandmother um
oh get back to me on that one get back
to me on that one
oh well that's no grandma lee behavior
i can't use that here
oh
oh my god i got out of there just in
time okay whoa
whoa okay man i still haven't gotten
what i need though
because i need the thing to spawn in the
hallway so that i can get the coins
i think it's you but god damn i didn't
get the actual thing
[Music]
let's go for it doesn't matter anyway
win or lose
it's all the same
oh what
what
i'm up and at him i'm feel energized
full of vim vigor even
mr dover
yeah yeah you just call me
i got it okay so i didn't get what i
needed
so i got to go back in i don't know how
many times is gonna require i was
getting that scene every single time
for a while
so i just gotta keep trying there's one
more ending i'm gonna get it it's
elusive but i want it i want it
i want it
[Music]
oh
my god hello uh
hold on hold on hold on
wait right there
oh
fascinating
fascinating fascinating fascinating i
put the necklace around his neck and he
cherished it
interesting okay if i can just get the
other one now i should be good to go
oh not this again
whoa
what
if you are experiencing this error for
the first time locate poisonous material
ingest and wait for heart rate to slow
your flesh is wasted give it to me let
me in your glorious pleasure zach to
flood your veins as you run dormant
there's no hope you will see me
okay last i didn't notice that's before
man what did i do to get that to happen
so much i don't know maybe just because
i had this
plugged in so it thought i was like
farther than i maybe thought i was like
oh you must be pretty far because giving
me very baseline stuff right it's giving
me like basic [__] level stuff it's got
to give me the advanced [__] you know
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying you know what i'm saying
whoa my god what in the hell is that oh
my god
what
holy crap what is on your
back
what in the hell was that
oh
i mean i guess it's a dead body but holy
[__] man i cannot get this thing to
spawn i don't know how it keeps giving
me like older beginning of game
kind of things and visions and i'm like
i know what to do
i'm just not seeing the thing where i
can do it
you know what i mean
okay
i
[Music]
gotcha here oh hi
rebecca
oh no
oh boy
i saw that though
i saw that
oh god
oh my god
no i knew it i knew it i knew it's you i
knew it
you but that doesn't matter
because now what i'm trying to get
hello
hmm
wow
all right there's that but still not
what i need oh god how many times am i
gonna have to redo this
whoa wait wait wait wait wait what
hey little love
what
dad
i'm here
it's all right
you're safe oh my god dad
hey
sweetie it's all right
i ruined everything no no
my little girl don't do this to yourself
if you've suffered enough
you're not like her rebecca
your mother
she gave up on life long before she died
what happened to me was the result of
choices you should have never been
exposed to
you changed your life
but i'm so proud you changed too
not before i heard
you sweetie
you can't do this to yourself
don't remember me like
this
[Music]
i
don't want to forget you
if you relive that night over and over
you'll only remember pain
the best of me is in you sweetie
i'm with you forever i just
miss you so much
every day life
i know it's hard
but you know where to go
[Music]
you've already found it
souls are suffering rebecca
but you can help them
you can bring comfort and closure to the
living
and let the dead rest
let the dead rest rebecca
i love you dad
i love you
i did i i did it i did i did it
[Music]
i finally did it
i beat you
oh wow i think that's because i gave uh
the dad the necklace right at the moment
i didn't know if that would count
i
did it
i beat you
ending five of five my god i did it that
was fun it took a long time though it's
just like
it's fun when you it's still new and
novel but towards the end it was getting
a little repetitive because i think i'd
seen all the spooks that there were to
see but there you have it all endings
done
in night vision spooks to the maximum
i'm very happy with that that was very
fun i i felt like i wanted to beat it
which is something i don't usually get
in horror games even if they get a
little repetitive there so this was very
good i enjoyed this thoroughly thank you
so much for making this a really nice
experience that was just so contained it
didn't need to be too huge in terms of
what you're doing because just what
you're doing is morbid enough and the
theme is scary enough and the spooks are
random enough that it can get you
creeped out even if you played it many
many times over so thank you everybody
so much for watching check out more
scary games in the description below or
anywhere on my channel go check out
distractable and go my favorite sports
team for
your podcast related fun
and thanks again
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you